[Music]
thank you
at the very beginning spider is looking
at a clock and worried about what time
it is
spider is a little obsessive-compulsive
and they are a butler or a you know a
helper in the house and responsible for
making the Party happen
[Music]
MIT students from the digital art and
animation community on campus teaming up
with Dr Elena Brewer we create
animations and get third creators in the
community involved in its production
the idea was that the third graders
would draw pictures of insects and that
those pictures would then get
incorporated into the film
[Music]
but we would also go and talk to them
about art and music and their Fusion
Arya assembled a team of eight animators
she coached them on the various software
that they used to make the film
they had to write a storyboard they had
to have character design they had to
make backgrounds and time it to the
music
[Music]
it was really the leadership aspect of
the MLK awards that I thought was
particularly suited to Arya it was like
she was running a business I mean she
was just so good
how wonderful she was with the third
graders
she's just really encouraging supportive
and fun
she really enjoyed working with those
kids
[Music]
if you have a skill if you have a gift
there's going to be a way in which you
can give back to the community
foreign